Comme vous l'avez remarqué, à chaque fois que vous venez ici, vous apprenez quelque chose.
Ce matin, les experts mondiaux
venant de trois ou quatre entreprises de fabrication de sièges,
ont conclu, je pense, que finalement, la solution est que les gens ne devraient pas s'assoir.
J'aurais pu le leur dire.
(Rires)
Hier, les types de l'automobile nous présentaient leurs nouvelles idées.
Ils ont souligné que, je crois que c'était d'ici 30 ou 50 ans,
ils dirigeraient les voitures par l'électricité,
sans toute cette mécanique.
(Rires)
C'est rassurant.
(Applaudissements)
Ensuite ils ont sougligné qu'il y aurait, en quelques sorte, d'autres commandes électriques,
pour se débarrasser de toute cette mécanique.
C'est pas mal, mais pourquoi ne pas supprimer les fils électriques ?
Ensuite, vous n'avez plus besoin de rien pour contrôler votre voiture, sauf d'y penser.
J'adorerais parler de la technologie,
et un de ces jours, après les 15 minutes,
je serais content de parler à tous les mordus de technologie présents ici
de ce qu'il y a là dedans.
Mais si je devais dire une chose à ce propos, avant même de commencer,
ça serait que au moment où nous avons démarré sa fabrication,
l'idée principale n'était pas la technologie.
Ça a réellement été une grande idée technologique quand nous avons commencé à l'appliquer
à l'iBOT pour les personnes handicapées.
Ici, la grande idée est, je pense, une nouvelle solution
à un problème de transport majeur.
Pour mettre cela en perspective : il y a tellement de données là-dessus,
je serai content de vous les donner sous différentes formes.
Vous ne savez jamais qui est séduit par telle ou telle idée,
mais tout le monde admettra volontiers que la voiture a changé le monde.
Quand Henry Ford lança, il y a tout juste 100 ans, le modèle T.
Mais il y a une chose à laquelle je ne crois pas que beaucoup de gens pensent,
c'est le contexte dans lequel une technologie intervient.
Par exemple, à cette époque, 91 pour cent des américains
vivaient dans des fermes ou des petites villes.
Donc la voiture --
la carriole sans cheval qui remplaça le cheval et la carriole -- était un gros progrès ;
ça allait deux fois plus vite qu'une carriole à cheval.
C'était deux fois moins long.
Et c'était un progrès environnemental, car par exemple,
en 1903 ils interdirent les chevaux et les carrioles dans le centre-ville de Manhattan,
parce que vous pouvez imaginer ce à quoi les routes ressemblent
quand vous avez un million de chevaux,
dont un million qui urinent, entre autres,
et la typhoïde et d'autres problèmes créés étaient presque inimaginables.
Donc la voiture était l'alternative propre et environnementale au cheval et à la carriole.
C'était également une façon pour les gens d'aller de ferme en ferme,
ou de ferme en village, ou du village jusqu'en ville.
C'était totalement rationnel, avec 91 pour cent des gens vivant là.
Dans les années 50, on commença à connecter toutes les villes entre elles
avec ce que certains considèrent comme la huitième merveille du monde : le réseau d'autoroutes.
Et c'est sans aucun doute une merveille.
En passant, alors que je critique les vieilles technologies,
je veux promettre à tout le monde, et à l'industrie automobile en particulier --
qui a été d'un grand support pour nous --
que je ne pense pas que cela concurrence les avions en quoi que ce soit, ou les voitures.
Mais pensez à là où en est le monde aujourd'hui.
50 pour cent de la population mondiale vit désormais en ville.
Ça fait 3.2 milliards de personnes.
Nous avons résolu tous les problèmes de transport
qui on changé le monde pour nous amener là où nous sommes aujourd'hui.
Il y a 500 ans, naviguer sur des voiliers commençait à être suffisamment fiable;
on a trouvé un nouveau continent.
Il y a 150 ans, les locomotives devinrent suffisamment efficaces, avec la vapeur,
pour que nous transformions le continent en un pays.
Sur les 100 dernières années, on commençait à fabriquer des voitures,
puis en l'espace de 50 ans on a connecté toutes les villes entre elles
de façon extraordinairement efficace,
et nous avons un très haut niveau de vie grâce à ça.
Mais pendant tout ce processus, de plus en plus de personnes sont nées,
et de plus en plus de personnes déménagent vers les villes.
La Chine à elle seule va déplacer de quatre à six cent millions de personnes
vers les villes dans les quinze prochaines années.
Et de même, personne, je pense, ne discutera le fait que les avions, durant les 50 dernières années,
ont transformé le continent et le pays en un quartier.
Et si vous regardez la façon dont la technologie a été appliquée,
nous avons résolu tous les problèmes de distance, de vitesse, de volume,
de poids pour tout ce qui se déplace.
Personne ne voudrait se passer de cela.
Et je ne voudrais certainement pas abandonner mon avion,
ou mon hélicoptère, ou mon Hummer, ou ma Porsche.
Je les aime tous. Je n'en garde aucun dans mon salon.
En fait, le problème est le dernier kilomètre,
la moitié du monde vit maintenant dans des villes denses.
Les gens dépensent, selon qui ils sont,
entre 90 et 95 pour cent de leur énergie à se déplacer à pied.
Je crois qu'il y a -- je ne sais pas quelles statistiques vous impressionneraient,
mais à peu près 43 pour cent du pétrole raffiné dans le monde
est consommé par des voitures dans les zones métropolitaines des Etats-Unis.
Trois millions de personnes meurent chaque année dans les villes à cause de la mauvaise qualité de l'air,
et la quasi-totalité de la pollution particulaire sur cette planète
est produite par les moyens de transport, particulièrement en ville.
Et à nouveau, je ne dis pas cela pour attaquer quelque industrie que ce soit,
je pense -- vraiment -- j'aime mon avion,
et les voitures roulant à 110 km/h sur l'autoroute
sont extraordinairement efficaces,
à la fois du point de vue de l'ingénierie,
au niveau de la consommation d'énergie, et du point de vue utilitaire.
Nous aimons tous nos voitures, et moi aussi je les aime.
Le problème, c'est que vous arrivez en ville et vous voulez aller quatre pâtés de maisons plus loin,
ce n'est ni drôle, ni efficace, ni productif.
Ce n'est pas durable.
Si -- en Chine, en 1998, 417 millions de personnes utilisaient leur vélo ;
1.7 million utilisaient des voitures.
Si cinq pour cent de cette population devenait, disons, des classes moyennes
et voulait suivre le chemin que nous avons suivi durant les cent dernières années
alors que dans le même temps 50 pour cent de leur population migrent vers des villes
de la taille et densité de Manhattan, toutes les six semaines --
ce n'est pas durable pour l'environnement,
ce n'est pas durable économiquement -- il n'y a tout simplement pas assez de pétrole.
Et ce n'est pas durable politiquement.
En fait, contre quoi nous battons nous en ce moment ?
On peut rendre ça compliqué, mais contre quoi le monde se bat-il maintenant ?
Il m'a donc semblé qu'il fallait que quelqu'un travaille sur ce dernier kilomètre,
et c'était une aubaine ; nous étions en train de travailler sur les iBOTS.
Mais après avoir fini ça, nous avons décidé instantanément
que cela pourrait être une belle alternative aux jet skis. Vous n'avez pas besoin d'eau.
Ou aux motoneiges. Vous n'avez pas besoin de neige.
Ou au ski. C'est juste marrant, et les gens adorent se déplacer en faisant des trucs marrants.
Et chacune de ces industries, au passage --
les voiturettes de golf sont un marché industriel de plusieurs milliards de dollars à elles seules.
Mais plutôt que d'aller déposer des licences pour cela, ce que nous faisons habituellement,
il m'a semblé que si nous mettions tous nos efforts non pas dans la technologie,
mais dans la compréhension d'un monde qui a résolu tous ses autres problèmes,
mais qui en est venu à accepter tant bien que mal que les villes -- qui,
depuis la Grèce antique, étaient conçues pour les piétons,
les villes qui étaient dessinées et bâties pour les personnes --
ont maintenant une empreinte environementale, et ceci,
alors que nous avons résolu tous les autres problèmes de transport --
et c'est comme la loi de Moore.
Je veux dire, regardez le temps que ça prenait pour traverser le continent dans les charriots des pionniers,
puis en train, puis en avion.
Toutes les autres formes de transport ont été améliorées.
En 5000 ans, nous avons régressé pour les déplacements en ville.
Elles sont devenues plus grosses, elles se sont étalées.
L'immobilier le plus cher de la planète, dans chacune des villes --
Wilshire Boulevard, la cinquième avenue, Tokyo, ou Paris --
l'immobilier le plus cher est leur centre-ville.
65% de la surface de nos villes correspond aux voitures garées.
Pour les 20 plus grandes villes du monde.
Donc vous vous demandez, et si les villes pouvaient donner à leurs piétons
ce que nous considérons comme acquis lorsque nous allons entre les villes ?
Et si on pouvait les rendre amusantes, attirantes, propres,
respectueuses de l'environnement ?
Et si cela rendait un peu plus agréable
d'y accéder via cela, en dernier maillon du transport collectif,
pour arriver jusqu'à vos voitures afin de pouvoir tous vivre en banlieue
et utiliser notre voiture comme on veut,
et puis avoir nos villes vivantes à nouveau ?
Nous nous sommes dit que ça serait vraiment génial de faire ça,
et un des problèmes qui nous a vraiment inquiété
est comment monter légalement sur le trottoir,
car techniquement j'ai des moteurs, j'ai des roues -- je suis dans un véhicule à moteur.
Je ne ressemble pas à un véhicule à moteur.
J'occupe la même surface au sol qu'un piéton,
J'ai la même capacité unique
à me débrouiller avec d'autres piétons dans un espace bondé.
J'ai pris ça jusqu'à Ground Zero,
et je me suis frayé un chemin à travers la foule pendant une heure.
Je suis un piéton. Mais la loi a typiquement une génération ou deux de retard sur la technologie,
et si on nous dit que nous n'avons pas notre place sur le trottoir, nous avons deux choix.
Soit nous sommes un véhicule de loisir qui ne compte pas vraiment,
et je ne perds pas mon temps à faire ce genre de trucs,
soit peut-être que nous devrions être sur la chaussée
devant un autocar de tourisme ou un véhicule.
Nous avons été si préoccupés par cela,
que nous avons été voir le chef des postes des Etats Unis,
la première personne extérieure à qui nous nous sommes montrés,
et dit, "Mettez des gens dessus, tout le monde fait confiance à son postier.
Et ils sont sur les trottoirs, et ils vont l'utiliser sérieusement."
Il a été d'accord. Nous sommes allés voir de nombreux commissariats de police :
il voulaient que leurs officiers de police retournent dans les quartiers
sur le bitume, portant 35 kilos de trucs. Ils adorent ça.
Et je n'arrive pas à croire qu'un policier va se donner une contravention à lui-même.
(Rires)
Donc nous avons travaillé très, très dur,
mais nous savions que la technologie ne serait pas aussi dure à développer
qu'une attitude sur ce qui est important, et que la manière d'appliquer la technologie.
Nous sommes sortis et nous avons trouvé des visionnaires
avec suffisamment d'argent pour nous laisser concevoir et construire ces choses,
et en nous laissant, j'éspère, suffisamment de temps pour qu'ils soient acceptés.
Donc, je suis content, vraiment, je suis content de parler de cette technologie autant que vous le voulez.
Et oui, c'est vraiment amusant, et oui, vous devriez tous sortir et l'essayer.
Mais si je pouvais vous demander de faire une chose,
c'est de ne pas le considérer comme de la technologie,
mais juste d'imaginer que, bien que nous comprenions tous finalement
qu'il est raisonnable d'utiliser notre engin de 2 tonnes,
qui peut aller à 100 km/h,
qui peut vous emmener ou vous voulez,
et bizarrement nous l'utilisons aussi pour le dernier kilomètre,
et c'est cassé, et ça ne marche pas.
Une des choses les plus excitantes qui nous soit arrivé,
qui fera que ça sera peut-être accepté, se passa ici en Californie.
Il y a quelques semaines, après le lancement,
nous étions ici avec une équipe de journalistes à Venice Beach, faisant des allers-retours à toute allure,
et ils s'émerveillent sur la technologie,
et pendant ce temps les vélos passent à toute allure,
et les skateboarders passent à toute allure,
et une petite vieille dame -- je veux dire, si vous regardez dans le dictionnaire,
une vieille petite dame -- vint vers moi --
et moi je suis là-dessus, j'ai une taille d'adulte normal maintenant --
et elle s'arrête simplement, et la caméra est là, et elle me regarde
et dit, "je peux l'essayer ?"
Et qu'est ce que j'allais -- vous savez, comment voulez-vous dire quelque chose ?
Et donc je dis, "bien sûr."
Donc je descends, elle monte dessus, et c'est pourtant pas commun, hein
elle tourne et roule environ 8 mètres,
et fait demi tour, et elle a un grand sourire.
Et elle revient vers moi et s'arrête, puis dit,
"Enfin, ils ont fait quelque chose pour nous."
Et la caméra la fixe.
Je pense, "Wahou, c'était génial --
(Rires)
-- s'il vous plait, madame, ne dites plus un seul mot."
Et la caméra la fixe
et il faut qu'il y ait ce gars qui lui tende le micro,
et dise, "Qu'est-ce que vous voulez dire pas là ?"
Et je pense, "C'est raté maintenant,"
et elle lève le regard et dit, "Eh bien,"
elle est encore en train de regarder ces gars qui roulent, elle dit "je ne peux pas faire de vélo", non,
elle dit, "je ne sais pas faire de skateboard, et je n'ai jamais fait de roller, "
elles les connaissait de nom ;
elle dit, "et cela fait 50 ans que je n'ai plus fait de vélo".
Puis elle lève les yeux, elle regarde en l'air, et elle dit,
"J'ai 81 ans, et je ne conduis plus de voiture,
je dois encore aller jusqu'aux magasins, et je ne peux pas porter grand-chose."
Et soudain il me vint à l'esprit, que parmi mes nombreuses peurs,
il n'y avait pas seulement le fait que la bureaucratie et les régulateurs
et les législateurs ne comprendraient peut-être pas,
mais c'était que, fondamentalement, vous pensez qu'il y a une demande populaire
pour ne pas envahir le moindre bout du précieux espace disponible,
les trottoirs de ces villes.
Quand vous regardez les 90 cm imposés par la loi pour les trottoirs,
puis les 2 m 40 pour les places de stationnement, puis les 3 voies de circulation,
et puis à nouveau 2 m 40 -- c'est --
ce petit bout, c'est tout ce qui reste.
Mais elle relève la tête et dit ça,
et il m'a semblé, même si les enfants ne vont pas se préoccuper de ces choses,
et qu'ils ne votent pas, et même si les gens du business et puis les jeunes adultes
ne vont pas se préoccuper de cela, ils sont plutôt sympa,
je crois que inconsciement, j'étais inquiet
du fait que la population âgée allait s'inquiéter.
Donc, en ayant vu cela, et m'en étant inquiété pendant huit ans,
la première chose que j'ai fait, c'est prendre mon téléphone et demander à nos gars du marketing et du droit,
appelez l'Association Américaine des Personnes Retraitées, prenez un rendez-vous immédiatement.
Nous devons leur montrer cette chose.
Et ils ont emmené ça à Washington, ils leur ont montré,
et ils vont être impliqués maintenant,
en voyant comment ces choses s'intègrent dans de nombreuses villes,
comme à Atlanta, où nous faisions des essais pour voir si cela pouvait réellement
aider à revitaliser leur centre-ville.
(Applaudissements)
Le facteur décisif est, que vous fassiez confiance aux Nations Unies,
ou à quelque autre groupe de réflexion --
dans les vingt prochaines années, toute la croissance en population de cette planète
sera dans les villes.
Pour la seule Asie, ça sera plus d'un milliard de personnes.
Ils ont démarré directement avec les téléphones portables.
Ils n'ont pas eu à emprunter le même chemin de 100 ans que nous.
Ils commencent au top de la chaine alimentaire de la technologie.
Nous devons commencer à construire des villes et des environnements humains
où quelqu'un de 75 kg peut se déplacer sur quelques kilomètres
dans un environnement dense, riche, avec des espaces verts,
sans être dans une machine de 2 tonnes pour faire cela.
Les voitures n'ont pas été inventées pour se garer en parallèle ;
ce sont de merveilleuses machines pour aller entre les villes, mais pensez-y bien :
nous avons résolu tous ces problèmes de longue distance et de haute vitesse.
Les Grecs allaient du théâtre de Dionysos au Parthénon en sandales.
Vous le faites en baskets.
Ça n'a pas changé tant que cela.
Si cette chose va seulement trois fois plus vite que la marche -- 3 fois --
une marche de 30 minutes devient 10 minutes.
Votre choix, quand vous vivez en ville, si c'est désormais 10 minutes --
parce que pour 30 minutes vous voulez une alternative, que ce soit un bus, un train.
Pour cela nnous devons construire une infrastructure -- des rails de tramway --
ou alors vous allez continuer à garer ces voitures.
Mais si vous pouviez placer une punaise sur la carte d'une ville,
et imaginer jusqu'où vous pourriez, si vous aviez le temps, aller à pied en une demi-heure : c'est toute la ville.
Si vous pouviez rendre ça amusant, et le faire en 8 ou 10 minutes,
vous n'avez pas à trouver votre voiture, la sortir du parking, la déplacer,
la garer et aller quelque part;
vous n'irez plus prendre un taxi ou le métro.
Nous pourrions changer la façon dont les gens allouent leurs ressources,
la façon dont cette planète utilise son énergie,
rendre cela plus marrant.
Et nous espérons en quelques sorte que l'histoire dira que nous avions raison.
Voici le Segway. Et voici un moteur Stirling ;
il avait été un peu oublié avec tout ce que nous faisons.
Cette petite bête, là, produit quelques centaines de Watts d'électricité.
Oui, ça pourrait être attaché à ça,
et oui, avec un kilogramme de propane,
vous pourriez aller de New York à Boston si vous le désiriez.
Mais ce qui est peut-être plus intéressant à propos de ce petit engin c'est qu'il brule n'importe quel carburant,
car certains d'entre vous sont peut-être sceptiques
quant à l'impact que cela pourrait avoir,
alors que la plupart des gens ont juste à le brancher dans leur prise de courant.
Nous avons travaillé là-dessus,
en fait, comme une source d'énergie alternative,
en commençant il y a longtemps avec Johnson & Johnson, pour faire fonctionner un iBOT,
car les meilleures batteries que vous pouviez avoir --
10 Watt-heure par kilogramme en plomb,
20 Watt-heure par kilogramme en nickel cadmium,
40 Watt-heure par kilogramme en nickel-hydrure métallique,
60 Watt-heure par kilogramme en lithium,
8750 Watt-heure d'énergie dans chaque kilogramme de propane ou d'essence -
c'est pourquoi personne ne conduit de voiture électrique.
Mais, dans tous les cas, si vous pouvez le brûler avec le même rendement --
car c'est une combustion externe -- comme dans votre gazinière,
si vous pouvez brûler n'importe quel carburant, ça devient plutôt séduisant.
Cela produit tout juste assez d'électricité pour, par exemple, faire ça,
ce qui, pendant la nuit, est assez d'électricité, pour le reste du monde,
comme M. Holly -- Dr. Holly -- l'a remarqué,
peut faire marcher un ordinateur et allumer une ampoule.
Mais, et c'est plus intéressant, la thermodynamique nous dit
que l'on n'aura jamais une efficacité supérieure à 20%.
Ce n'est pas si grave -- cela veut dire que si vous obtenez 200 W d'électricité,
vous aurez sept ou huit cents watts de chaleur.
Si vous vouliez faire bouillir de l'eau et la re-condenser à un rythme de 40 litres par heure,
il faut pour cela environ 25, un plus, 25.3 kilowatts --
25000 watts de puissance continue -- pour le faire.
C'est tellement d'énergie que vous ne pourriez pas dessaler
ou nettoyer l'eau dans ce pays de cette façon.
C'est sûr, dans le reste du monde, vous pouvez dévaster le lieu,
en transformant tout ce qui brule en chaleur, ou boire l'eau qui est disponible.
La première cause de mortalité humaine sur cette planète est la mauvaise qualité de l'eau.
En fonction ceux à qui vous faites confiance pour vos chiffres,
cela fait entre 60 et 85000 personnes par jour.
Nous n'avons pas besoin de greffes de cœurs compliquées à travers le monde.
Nous avons besoin d'eau.
Et les femmes ne devraient pas être obligées de passer quatre heures par jour pour en chercher,
sous peine de voir leurs enfants mourir.
Nous avons réussi à mettre un distillateur à compression de vapeur sur ce truc,
avec un échangeur thermique à contre courant pour récupérer la chaleur perdue,
puis en utilisant quelques contrôles électriques, ce procédé,
avec 450 watts, ce qui un peu plus que la moitié de sa chaleur perdue,
il va faire 40 litres d'eau distillée par heure
à partir de ce que l'on a mis dedans pour le refroidir.
Donc si nous mettons cette boite ici dans quelques années,
pourrons-nous avoir une solution au transport, à l'électricité,
et la communication, et peut-être à l'eau potable
dans un ensemble durable qui pèse 30 kilos ?
Je ne sais pas, mais on va essayer.
Je ferais mieux de me taire.
(applaudissements)